alors francis j'aimerais ce soir parce
que on a eu la version continue on l'a
diffusée ici et je suis franchement on
n'a personne n'a remis en cause cette
version mais oui c'est ça qui était
incroyable parce que quand on voit les
images on voit bien que je n'aime pas
frappé alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé
exactement a contenu déjà je vais
répondre parce que yann c'est que des
faits qui news et c'est que des
mensonges dont j'ai déjà répondre au
deuxième mensonge
une plainte a été déposée voilà donc
cher monsieur je vous conseille voilà
j'ai interrogé le j'ai fait interroger
le parquet d'avignon parce que c'est lui
qui est compétent un par mon avocat
donc c'est une lettre officielle que je
vais te lire cher monsieur je vous
confirme avoir interrogé ce jour le
service du parquet de monsieur le
procureur de la république d'avignon
lesquels m'ont confirmé qu'aucune
plainte n'a été enregistrée par le
journaliste du quotidien à votre
encontre d'accordéon à surya passé c'est
un mensonge d'accord c'est l'un de plus
importants permis ça c'est voilà donc ça
veut dire tune un vrai document que
c'est un mensonge
pas d'accord il n'y a pas de plaintes
désir d'arriver parlons parlant du
certificat médical faut arrêter de se
[ __ ] de la gueule des gens quand il ya
par exemple coups et blessures
la procédure c'est que juste après les
faits tu te rends dans un hôpital
1 parce qu'il faut établir un lien de
causalité entre le coût et la blessure
donc tu dois faire constater tout de
suite que tu es blessé et indiquer d'où
tu viens
et d'où vient le coup donc c'est pas le
lendemain ou le surlendemain tu fais ça
parce que sinon tu peux faire n'importe
quoi tu es peut l'être mettre un coup
sur la tête chez toi pour dire c'est lui
qui m'a frappé parce qu'il est riche
qu'est donc normalement si je l'avais
frappé la procédure c'est déjà le cas il
a pris un coup déjà il est tombé par
terre ce qu'il y n'ait la liste n'est
pas le cas déjà il a une marque déjà
gars ça se voit déjà
il va crier va pleurer va y avoir des
photos il ya rien de tout ça moi j'ai
une cinquantaine de témoignages en plus
de gens qui vont à tester que le jeu
n'ait donné aucun coup mais ça c'est pas
très grave mais parlons de ce fameux
certificat médical alors tu dois te
rendre dans un hôpital
sais tu dois te rendre à lui mj l'unité
médico-judiciaire pourquoi parce que
c'est la seule qui est habilité à
établir un lien de causalité entre le
coût et la blessure et de décréter
effectivement qui à coups et blessures
te faire un certificat médical deux
coups et blessures et en plus te donner
une unité c'est à dire qu'elle
statuer sur le bien-fondé de l'it été et
sur la durée de l'itt été n'a pas ça du
tout ils sont pas du tout aller à l'alu
mj d'avignon ils sont restés
tranquillement à la fête ils ont monté
tout une espèce de mise en scène ou des
semblants de partir ils sont revenus et
après j'ai plein d'image plein de photos
pl de deux trucs filmé avec des
portables on les vois rigoler entre eux
même discuté de ce qu'ils vont faire et
c'est tout est enregistré j'ai des
témoignages et tout ce qui s'est passé
alors atteint 2 secondes et donc et dont
je continue je te lis est ce que je peux
terminer après et après donc ils sont
partis tranquillement il avait aucune
marque on a toutes les images etc
et le surlendemain ils vont à cochin
alors je ne crois pas du tout je ne
crois pas du tout que qui que ce soit à
l'hôpital cochin peut s'amuser à faire
une fausse attestation ça c'est sûr la
banque sérieuse j'espère qu'ils vont pas
s'amuser à faire ce qu'on appelle un
certificat de complaisance
parce que ça ça s'appelle un faux en
écriture publique et j'imagine pas du
tout le reste pour cette finale
ce que tu as dit allez porter plainte
oui messieurs dames âgées dépendantes et
là c'est le deuxième but
c'est le deuxième document que j'ai ici
donc moi je porte plainte pour l'instant
devant la la commission de déontologie
le conseil de déontologie journalistique
parce que je trouve que la conduite de
ces gens-là offense le journaliste mais
j'ai le plus grand respect pour la
protection des journalistes
mais ces gens là c'est pas des
journalistes parce que les des
folliculaires pendant qu'ils t'ont
apostrophé sans te demander non s'il
pouvait être filmé ou pas c'est ça non
parce que ces gens là font pas du
journalisme
ils font du sensationnalisme ce sont des
folliculaires selon l'expression de
voltaire tu regarderas au dictionnaire
beaucoup de joie voilà non je plaisante
et donc est donc ces gens là quand ils
viennent par exemple aux université
citoyenne
ils viennent pas du tout faire un
reportage sur les citoyens français qui
se réunissent pour réfléchir ensemble
sur comment apporter une alternative
citoyenne à la politique politicienne
dont il cherche les gars qui vont
pouvoir mettre à mal en leur volant des
images en leur posant des questions les
chauffant en essayant et ensuite au
montage de trafiquer les images quand
on